whether we think about them or not the
people and institutions around us
influence every aspect of our lives in
our workplaces with our families in
churches even simply walking down the
street every day there are hidden social
forces that affect our every move and
influence our outcomes brian lowry is a
professor at the stanford graduate
school of business and a social
psychologist by training
he was also a guest on a previous
episode of grit and growth
join brian for know what you see a
podcast where he talks to people from a
wide range of backgrounds and
perspectives about their experiences
with the social forces framing our world
[Music]
when we lead with dominance it tends to
look more authoritative and when we lead
with something more deferential
that involves showing respect to others
that's more approachable it invites
others to engage with us more
power
it's that invisible force that governs
our world
some want it some warn against it
but what is it exactly and how do you
use power for good so one of the big
myths i think is that dominance is
always better for example than being
deferential and i would suggest that's
not true at all it's very very useful to
show up in a way that's disarming as a
way of building relationships and making
things work
[Music]
welcome to the second season of grit and
growth from stanford c the show where
africa and south asia's intrepid
entrepreneurs share their trials and
triumphs with insights from stanford
faculty on how to tackle challenges and
grow your business
today we're going to tackle that
mysterious force that can determine your
success as a leader and an entrepreneur
i'm talking about power
[Music]
entrepreneurs are constantly faced with
questions of power as they manage their
growing teams pitch to investors and
negotiate crucial deals for their growth
even if they don't use the term power or
think about power explicitly how much
power do you actually have in any given
situation and how would you know
when should you use it and when should
you yield
to help us think through those questions
i spoke with dr deborah grinfeld who has
been researching and teaching about
power for decades
my name is deborah gruenfeld i'm a
faculty member in the graduate school of
business at stanford and i teach in the
organizational behavior group and i
understand you're a psychologist by
training i am a psychologist by training
i study the psychology of power and
powerlessness
and is it common that a psychologist is
working at a business school
it's become more common over the years
power is a topic that's of interest to
people in all kinds of organizations
it's interesting to me psychologically
but it's sort of the central force in
most
social and business contexts yeah
business students are very interested in
the topic as well
power's defined as a person's capacity
to
get others to do what they want them to
despite resistance
so it's a kind of leverage leverage is
how it's normally defined yeah
i should make a distinction for you so
what i just described for you is the
definition of social power and often i
think of the type of power that i teach
about mostly as being related to
personal power so let me just make that
distinction for you quickly social power
comes from things like having
relationships in which others need you
more than you need them so that gives
you leverage having
good alternatives to a current
relationship is also a source of
leverage in that way
personal power tends to come from the
way you behave
and your impact on other people
independent of your ability to force
them to do things
i just want to repeat what deborah said
because i think it's a really
instructive framework she distinguishes
two types of power social power which
lets you influence others to do things
they wouldn't otherwise do
and personal power which allows you to
control your own outcomes independent of
others
i asked deborah what misconceptions she
sees about power
i mean i think the biggest one is that
most people tend to think of power as
something that only other people have
so we tend to think of powerful people
as famous people wealthy people you know
president of the united states or the
head of some other government
but those of us who study power
understand that every relationship has
power in it so to the extent that
in our relationship we need one another
in order to accomplish goals our goals
we have the ability to
influence one another to do things that
we care about because we want the
relationship to be successful and we
need one another
most of us feel like we have less power
than we do
and so we tend to feel powerless often
when we're not it's sort of independent
of how much power people have so one of
the really interesting things that i
found working in a business school is
that when i first started talking about
power to audiences i thought there'd be
it was kind of like a niche topic you
know that maybe there'd be some other
women who were interested in the
challenge of how to overcome feeling
powerless but one of the things i've
learned is that it's really a challenge
for everyone and even
see suite level executives are very
interested in the challenge of trying to
get comfortable with their own um their
own authority in their own
authoritativeness it's a kind of a
challenge that that really applies to
everyone and never seems to go away
[Music]
to many of us power is portrayed as
something to be wary of
but according to dr grenfell that's not
the whole story
so one of the really interesting things
that we found in our research is that
you know there's this idea that power
corrupts so power leads to bad behavior
almost by definition what we find
actually is that
it's really having power while feeling
powerless
that leads people to behave badly so it
leads people to want to do things that
are designed to make themselves feel
more powerful as opposed to doing things
in ways that are best for the
organization best for the team or best
for the people who report to them so
that's just to give you one one example
for those of us who have
insecurities about how important we are
how influential we are whether other
people respect us those insecurities
really never go away
but as you move up in your career what
you find is you just you just find
yourself on a bigger stage in which to
act those things out but the
psychological
sources of inferiority are very very
common and very hard to overcome so i
think one of the biggest challenges for
people moving into positions of power is
changing gears from thinking about
themselves as having
needs and wanting to feel power from
themselves to recognizing that with
great power comes great responsibility
and what they need to do is shift gears
toward thinking about what other people
need from them and to put other people's
needs first
it's important to reconceptualize power
in this way
because dr grenfell's research shows us
that power changes people
much of my work has really looked at
how finding yourself in a powerful
position is transformative in ways that
often happen
outside of our consciousness we're often
unaware that we're being transformed by
power but what our research shows is
that people tend to
become more focused on their own goals a
little more impulsive
and less sensitive to social norms when
in positions of power yeah so i'm
interested in pursuing that further
because i think about our audience of
entrepreneurs who might start out with
just an idea one or two members on a
team they find some success all of a
sudden they go from being
the founder who's almost a lone wolf to
actually having a team having investors
having a complex group of stakeholders
maybe having a board
and what does that do to them to their
psychology
i've spoken with a lot of these people
so i have a bit of a window on to that i
mean i think one of the most interesting
transitions
to observe and it's something that a lot
of us experience in our careers is just
that moment of recognizing that the
skills and tactics and techniques that
were successful for you to get you here
are not the same ones that you need to
get to where you're going next so a lot
of times what new company founders will
find for example is that they need to
learn to behave in a way
that's more authoritative
in order for other people to feel secure
in their presence with them in a
leadership role so it's very much a
challenge for people because often these
individuals don't feel
any different from one day to the next
going from being you know a technology
geek in a hoodie to being someone who
has hundreds of millions of dollars
invested in them they feel like exactly
the same person
but in order for other people to get
what they need in order to be successful
they have to learn how to show up in a
way that conveys authority and comfort
with power
and makes others feel more secure in
their presence
and it doesn't come naturally
[Music]
leaders often react to these changing
circumstances by pursuing authenticity
which surprisingly at least to me
turns out to not always be the right
answer
there's a difference between being
authentic and being who you need to be
yeah can you say a bit more about that
sure i mean it's such an interesting
topic especially when it comes to power
so you know the concern that i have is
that in the research that i've done
what happens to people when we put them
in positions of power and they're
authentic
is that they act very impulsively on
their own needs and desires without
consideration for their impact of their
behavior on anyone else
when people are concerned with
authenticity i think what they're
concerned about is feeling like
themselves and feeling like they're not
being false
what i think is much more important in a
position of power is to feel like you
can do whatever is necessary
in order for other people to get what
they need from you to me that's what it
means to act responsibly in a position
of power
so often it's not authentic it's often
doing something you could never have
imagined yourself doing
but that is necessary in order for the
rest of the team to feel like they're
safe they know their direction that
you've got your both hands on the
steering wheel when the world is turned
upside down
that's actually really helpful because
the first time i read that quote from
you i thought well
being authentic is almost like uh
unassailably good always right you
should always be yourself but actually
what if if your authentic self is
actually not very good that's exactly
things right then it's
not going to get you anywhere that's
exactly right there's interesting
research on authenticity now too coming
out that shows that often
when we behave in ways that feel
authentic
they don't read authentic that's
fascinating can you give me an example
so an example would be when someone
presents very anxious or hesitant or
uncertain about themselves like feeling
very self-conscious for example
that may feel very true
it also makes others feel like they're
watching someone who's covering
because they're not getting a pure
expression of something so it's one of
the biggest surprises i had when i
started to think about power from the
perspective of acting what actors do
which is that what i learned is that
whether you're doing something you've
never done before or not is not that
important what's important
is your commitment to what you're doing
and if you can find a way to genuinely
commit to behaving in a way that's
extremely confident even if you don't
feel confident people will think you're
confident and it will have the effect on
them that you want it to have
but if you don't feel confident and then
you try to behave as though you're
confident it reads like it's not true
[Applause]
so if we accept that power is at least
partially something we have to perform i
wondered what tools do we have at our
disposal
let's talk a little bit about the body
language of power what is that
one of the really interesting things
about power when you start to look at it
carefully is that humans and all other
animals spend a lot of time in social
hierarchies even more than we think we
do so we expect to see hierarchies in
power in you know business organizations
we don't
think about hierarchies in power in our
families but they're there too
and so what this means is that in pretty
much every social context
people tend to form hierarchies very
quickly whether it's needed or not to
accomplish the task and what this means
is that we're
negotiating for power and status all the
time without realizing it in the same
way that we know animals do
and so there are these very well learned
routines of behavior they're referred to
often as you know dominance and
submission or dominance and deference
that are ways of behaving physically
that signal to others
whether we're prepared to fight with
them or whether we're prepared to back
off and whether they should be afraid of
us or not and so it's it's really just
non-verbal
expressions or displays of dominance on
the one hand and submission on the other
that really makes up a large part of
what the body language of power
looks like it's how we communicate with
one another about
who ranks where
and
whether we're in agreement about that or
not
so i walk into a room full of strangers
i have to convince them of something
maybe i'm an entrepreneur and i'm trying
to convince a group of investors that my
big idea is great yeah
what are they noticing when i walk in
the room
one of the suggestions that i make to a
lot of entrepreneurs in these situations
is before going into a room like that
to imagine putting on a headdress so
we'll have a kind of a code like don't
forget to put on your headdress
and basically what this means is that if
you you can do this right now if you
imagine
that you're putting like a heavy crown
or like a headdress that would be worn
by a las
vegas showgirl or a chef's hat or
whatever it is if you can imagine
putting an elaborate headdress on your
head what you'll notice is that it
changes how you hold your body so if
you've got something heavy on your head
heavy and tall on your head you have to
keep your head still
you have to keep your neck and spine
straight up and down
and you have to
move slowly and carefully without a lot
of extraneous motion
that's one of the easiest things so we
know that stillness
as opposed to a lot of fleeting and
jerky movements communicates dominance
and power and also social comfort
and also physical expansiveness so one
of the things we know about dominance
one of the most reliable displays of
dominance is physical expansiveness
people will look at how quickly you move
how quickly you speak
whether your energy is focused as
opposed to kind of all over the place
which you know suggests
clarity of mind clarity of purpose
clarity of direction and confidence as
opposed to
hesitation and uncertainty these are all
things that
give people a sense of security that
you're comfortable in charge
in a previous episode of grit and growth
we featured communications expert matt
abrahams and he used the terms high
context and low context cultures
in a high context culture the
relationships the environment and the
situation are really important in how we
interact with other people and since we
exercise power through verbal and
non-verbal communication it's not
surprising that context matters here as
well
i've worked spent a lot of my career in
southeast asia in places where
hierarchy really matters so i worked in
a japanese bank and
basically everybody
was
incredibly physically deferential to the
boss
i remember the first time i walked in i
was like a 30 year old american guy and
everyone looked hunched over and scared
and i just and i didn't get it right
it's definitely the case that there are
cultures in which hierarchies are are
really sacred in a way that they're not
in western cultures in the united states
and in those cultures what ends up
happening i think what you witnessed
is that they're very
well learned and elaborated ways of
displaying
deference
to make sure that you never accidentally
offend someone who's above you in the
hierarchy by showing that you don't know
your place
what i think it conveys that i think is
really interesting and not intuitive to
people who think about power as kind of
a dark evil force is that hierarchies
and agreement about hierarchies is a
huge part of how we cooperate and avoid
fighting with one another this is why
you see it in the animal world as well
when we agree that one of us ranks
higher and the other ranks lower we
don't have to fight about it we can just
get down to business and accomplish the
task at hand
what you see more in the west and in
groups where hierarchies haven't been
established is people fight for position
they fight for status and power i think
we've all been in rooms where
that's happening and it absorbs a huge
amount of energy and resources that
in the animal kingdom you think of it as
like that energy should be going toward
the tasks that are necessary for
survival
so those very ritualized displays are
helpful in terms of people avoiding
making mistakes
that could derail cooperation in groups
if you're unsure where you stand in a
hierarchy debra has a strategy for
safely finding your place
what's the right way to approach a
situation where you don't know
the status hierarchy or it hasn't been
worked out yet or you're meeting someone
for the first time it's much safer to
slightly underestimate your rank to
behave in a way that's slightly more
deferential than necessary than it is to
behave in a way that's more dominant
than you have permission for
is very threatening to the people in
charge to have someone show up in a way
that suggests they can't read the room
and they don't understand that there's a
status hierarchy so what we often tell
people is that the safest strategy and
probably the most effective strategy is
to
take cues off the other person so if the
other person is showing up in a very
dominant way
it gives you permission
to be dominant
and to try to match what they're doing
but to stay just slightly
under just slightly more deferential
so that you're showing up
authoritatively enough to be taken
seriously but you're not threatening to
them pay attention to what other people
are doing
that'll give you a sense for what's
normative what looks appropriate try to
match but stay just slightly under
so that's a perfect segue to a framework
that i've i saw you introduce in a
lecture
about how you show up
whether you show up as approachable or
show up as authoritative and how that
might differ depending on where you are
in that hierarchy
in my mind there are really two
dimensions on which we're always being
evaluated one has to do with whether
we're perceived as strong and
authoritative or dominant
and the other has to do with whether
we're perceived as someone who's willing
to put other people's interests first
and when we lead with dominance
it tends to look more authoritative and
when we lead with something more
deferential that involves showing
respect to others that's more
approachable it invites others to engage
with us more
so one of the big myths i think is that
dominance is always better for example
than being deferential and i would
suggest that's not true at all it's very
very useful to show up in a way that's
disarming
as a way of building relationships and
and making things work
this spectrum of authoritative to
approachable presence can also be
helpful for people who aren't on top of
the social hierarchy
independent of how much power you have
we make choices all the time about
whether
to advertise
our advantages and our privileges and
our leverage or to camouflage those
things so yeah sometimes refer to it as
playing power up and playing it down
if i'm lower status in the hierarchy and
that's understood
is there ever a situation where i want
to use my body language to be more
assertive
from the point of view of someone who's
in a subordinate role
i think the most important thing
is that you reassure people who rank
higher than you do that you respect
their rank
to me the first step toward establishing
rapport and a trusting relationship with
a superior is letting them know that you
accept
that their rank is higher than yours
once you've established that respect and
that basis of trust it opens up all
kinds of opportunities you can present
very assertively you can disagree with
your boss you can because you've
established that you're not challenging
that that's exactly right now you're
offering that's right you're showing
confidence in your idea your proposal
and you've showed that you're doing it
because you're on their side
which is what i think is necessary in
order for a higher ranking person to
take um
more assertive behavior or challenges
from a subordinate is to be able to
trust that that person has the
superior's interest in mind i think it's
important to note that dr grundfeld
doesn't see authoritative or
approachable styles as wrong or right
but rather an effective leader needs to
blend both depending on the situation
there are many people who would say you
even as a high power person you should
always lead with
approachability
as a way of letting other people know
that although you don't have to
you're capable of putting their
interests first so one of the things we
know from research is that we don't tend
to give high-power people the benefit of
the doubt
on being
caring of others we tend to stereotype
high-power others as being very
self-interested
so some people would say the most
important thing for a high-powered
person is to reassure others
that they're capable of putting others
interests first they're not a complete
megalomaniac that's right and in many
cases i think that that's true
there is also research that shows
however the opposite which is that
specifically under
situations um crisis conditions where
there's a lot of
helplessness and uncertainty people tend
to crave
authoritarian or authoritative
leadership
the study that i'm referring to really
interesting looked at the relationship
between economic conditions around the
world and people's preferences for
authoritative versus more deferential
style political leaders but also more
authoritative and respect oriented
leaders in business
and what they found is that the worse
economic conditions were the more
economic uncertainty people were dealing
with the greater their preference
for strong dominant authoritative
leaders and i think in part it's because
we don't like dominance when it's
directed toward us we do like dominance
when we think people will use it to
protect us to resolve uncertainty it
gives us a sense of security to know
that someone is willing to take the risk
to fight for what's important to us and
so we're often more drawn to
authoritative leaders than you might
think
because they make us feel secure
we use the term which is not our term
it's from the gsb post-heroic leadership
which is
i need a team to solve adaptive
challenges how do you square that with
the need to actually
be visibly in charge in a crisis because
that's those are crises are also
adaptive challenges right how do you
make the choice between
showing up authoritative making
decisions and telling people what to do
versus asking for your team to help you
solve the problem or even handing it off
[Music]
in some ways the pandemic created a
natural if deeply unfortunate experiment
that allows us to compare and contrast
these leadership styles across countries
one of the things that's very
interesting is if you look at the prime
minister of new zealand she was a great
example
of balancing these two goals and being
able to use both of them so i think in a
situation like this what's ideal
is to have really empowered a set of
advisors and experts to advise you and
tell you what they think you should do
to couple that with
making the decision on your own and
publicly taking accountability for the
consequences of that decision so it's
sort of separating out the
being open to the input but then as the
leader being the person who owns
responsibility for the outcome so the
prime minister of new zealand actually
had has videos on youtube that show her
during the pandemic sitting at a kitchen
table in jeans and a t-shirt with her
two chief science advisors
obviously taking input from them as
though they're equals or more expert
than she is but then when she decides
how she's going to handle the lockdown
she shows up in a red jacket in front of
a microphone with all of her ministers
behind her and it's that combination of
things i think that can be really really
useful which is being willing to take
ownership
of the decisions
while at the same time understanding
that you'll probably be better off if
you take advice from
others
sometimes the best way to use your power
is simply to empower others
it's not intuitive at all for a person
in a leadership role who's dealing with
an adaptive challenge and doesn't know
how to approach it to go to your team
and say i'm lost
help me figure this out i mean it just
doesn't fit with how we think a leader
is supposed to behave
but of course those are the
opportunities where
you really engage your team and often
they know things that you don't know and
can help you solve the problems it's
just you know we get these ideas in our
head about what we're supposed to look
like in a position of power and we think
we're supposed to always be decisive and
always know the answers
and i think the other hidden benefit to
that being willing to show up
lost in a leadership role or vulnerable
let's say
is that your team feels like they've
helped you solve a problem that you
couldn't solve yourself it's hugely
motivating
so the benefits to you
they're not concerned about whether you
knew the answer didn't know the answer
they just feel
really good about themselves that they
were able to make a difference in your
life and i think that you know people in
leadership roles and positions of power
don't recognize
the loyalty and commitment that they can
get from their team by allowing them the
opportunity to help them
when you think about the logic of
empowering other people and what
research tells us about it is that
it is much better for motivating people
to give them more control over their
work and over their own decisions and
how they do things so the more people
feel in control of their outcomes the
more motivating that is
and at the same time there are
situations in which you benefit as a
leader by allowing other people to help
you so there's is that kind of sweet
spot and i set up a distinction that is
sometimes blurred in practice where your
ideal situation is where you've made a
decision
to help others succeed and that enables
your success as well
so that's exercising power with the
purpose of helping others
achieve what they need the way i like to
think of it is that
when you
allow someone to help you
as a person in a position of power who
it's often difficult to connect with
those people get in your corner
and it's one thing to want to be
respected and admired
and obeyed
and it's another to know that you have
people in your corner who will be there
for you if you fall off the pedestal
which happens
so um
it's loyalty respect admiration it's
sort of like an interesting kind of
reciprocity that if the person in charge
is
willing to take a personal risk in order
to
help you succeed you want to reciprocate
by taking personal risks to help them
succeed
for me a compelling takeaway from dr
grenfell's work is that power shouldn't
be a goal in itself but a means to an
end
people often ask me you know how should
i be trying to show up as a person in a
position of power and what i often tell
them is that they should be worried they
should be thinking about whether other
people trust them or not
and there are two aspects to trust one
has to do with
whether you're presenting in a way
that leads other people to think you're
capable or competent that's more using
the authoritative set of behaviors
and the other has to do with whether
others feel respected by you
and that has to do with the more
approachable deferential types of
behaviors so this idea of like
recognizing that to be successful you
need to be
equally capable
of behaving in a way that commands
respect and also being capable of
showing respect to others
as a way of being maximally effective
and
most of us are naturally better at one
of those than the other
so that's where there's um people can
reflect on their own strengths and
recognize where the opportunities for
growth are but the underlying goal is
trust yeah that's how i think about it
you know you can think of it as the
underlying goal is to get as much power
as you can maximize your leverage over
other people and have the upper hand in
every situation i'm not convinced that's
a helpful strategy i think there's a
lot of these people are downers yeah
that's that's right they are and and i
think there's a lot of research coming
out now
showing that there is no advantage
career-wise to being a jerk
it's more
useful from my point of view as a person
in a position of power who
wants to have a positive impact on
others and on the organizations that
they work in
to think about behaving in a way that
leads others to trust you more which you
know often has the effect of making you
more successful too
but it benefits others as well
dr gruenfeld's work offers fascinating
insights into how we see ourselves and
how we treat each other if you're in a
position of power remember that both
approachable and authoritative styles
have their place
sometimes we may be more comfortable
with one style over the other but
leaders need to practice types of power
that may not come naturally
for me one of the most surprising
research findings is that being true to
yourself
may not be as important as being the
leader that others need you to be
especially in crisis
and finally no matter how you display it
power should be used in the service of
trust
and making life better for those around
you
i'd like to thank dr deborah grunfeld
for coming on the podcast
she is as approachable as she is
authoritative
and as a reminder you can learn from
debra's expertise firsthand and in
person at the executive program in
women's leadership a one-week intensive
course which takes place at stanford
from may 1st to the 6th
to learn more about the program visit
the link in our show notes
this has been written growth with the
stanford graduate school of business and
i'm your host darius teeter
if you like this episode leave us a
review on your podcast app it really
helps us to share the stories of these
incredible entrepreneurs with as many
people as possible
to learn how stanford graduate school of
business is partnering with
entrepreneurs in africa and asia head
over to the stanford seed website at
seed.stanford.edu
podcast
grit and growth is a podcast by stanford
seed lori fuller and erica and moaka
ajay researched and developed content
for this episode
kendra gladice is our production
coordinator and our executive producer
is tiffany steves with writing and
production from andrew gannon in sound
design and mixing by alex bennett at
lower street media thanks for joining us
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you